So the question is, how
do you want to feel?
So I've become really
interested recently in this idea
of mediating experience.
OK?
Of directly engaging
the technical material
of subjectivity itself.
Of employing
technologies of rhetoric,
like language,
songs, storytelling,
cinema to capture
and control attention
and thrust one's
subjectivity into a state
of deep immersion, absorption.
A necessary precursor
for any kind
of interpersonal persuasion
or transformation or education
to take place
within one's psyche.
Janet Murray and her book
"Hamlet on the Holodeck"
talks about the fact that,
as narrative beings, we
long to be immersed.
We long to merge
with the narrative
to obliterate all
sense of separation.
To be enveloped in the mediated
environment, the story world.
We want to disappear and
come out on the other side.
And she says, so
powerful is our desire
to be immersed that it's not
just that we suspend disbelief,
but that we actively
create belief.
Using our sophisticated
intelligence
to reinforce our belief
in the story world
rather than to question it.
We actively metabolize
belief and story.
Knowing this then, the
challenge for the artist,
as he constructs the
cultural technologies
of the 21st century and
our technological desire
to virtualize reality,
we should keep in mind
that we have this
immense opportunity
to artfully and
creatively construct
these subjective story worlds.
And thus the narratives
of the future
have the potential to
literally transform
what it means to be human.
To employ landscapes of mind.
And turn subjective
experience into a living,
breathing painting.
A wake-walking lucid dream.
This is our opportunity.